you might think the Constitution is a
really boring thing A lot of people
do if you're going to understand the
form of our government you have to
understand something that's in the
Declaration of Independence as a
precursor what is the difference between
a human being and a dog be really good
wouldn't it to know what that thing is
what is the longest surviving written
constitution in human history oh come on
you guys got to be able to answer that
question the American Constitution we
have now named the elephant in the room
we're trying to explain the United
States of America we are social and we
are moral and therefore we are political
declaration good say lots of scholar
Constitution not so good what is the
relationship between them that's a big
story very big
story Divine Providence Creator laws of
nature and of Nature's God that's a very
radical thing to think the ultimate
source of human Freedom passion never
fails to rest the scepter from reason
I've always thought that that's
brilliant statement by Madison but also
not
true which one of you guys filled your
lunch on my sweater I know what to call
you we're going to call you
Spider-Man so my spyy senses tell me
that there we go it seems like the
Constitution is sort of the fruits of
those seeds that we saw in the
Declaration of Independence yeah we're
getting somewhere the loss of our
freedom is is reposing in the soul of
that girl right there that's kind of the
story of our country what's the good you
think you know you
there are questions here huge questions
we have a lot of thinking to
do we need fellow citizens who are
excellent fellow
[Music]
citizens